[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today there's
been so many different narratives going
around well maybe the government will
come you know forgive them maybe that'll
be the way out maybe some legislation
will be passed and there'll be caps put
in place uh maybe they should stop
making the loans altogether and so
there's a lot of a lot of thought and a
lot of uh different opinions about this
but Yahoo finance published an article
that said the US
government's biggest financial asset
John is student loan debt I'm going to
say that again the US government's
biggest financial asset is student loan
debt and I mean big time like over 1.1
trillion it says the value of Fally
backed student loans held by the
government has risen by more than a
th% since the last recession and now
tops at 1.1 trillion and if you're
watching on YouTube you can look at this
graph here student loans make up
45% 45% it says we hear a lot about
government debt but what we don't hear
about are government assets and so we're
looking at this and the Federal Reserves
Financial account data found that the
student loans make up the largest
financial asset held by the federal
government by a huge margin so I say all
that to say if we're waiting around for
the government to do something in the
way of maybe not making loans maybe
forgiving your loans anything that's
going to cause this to not be an asset I
think that we're going to be waiting
until the cows come home is basically
what I'm saying hell's basically going
to have to freeze over before that takes
place and then and I'm saying that
because here's I'm I want to light a
fear under people's butt right now a
fire and a fear to go hey I can't just
be willy-nilly about this like I can't
lolly gag with my student loans any
longer I've got to come up with a plan
to pay them off because hold on a second
before before we transition to that I
want to make sure everybody knows what
you just said because you used a fancy
Finance word called asset and I may not
have known what that was yes what we're
saying is or what what that report is
saying is the US government's emergency
fund is your student loan payment yeah
the US government what was it 40% was
45% put that against um throw that throw
that graph back up there yeah against
how much cash it has yeah this is so to
put in to put in perspective total
mortgages like when you have a mortgage
to the federal government
4.6% if we have the currency checkable
deposits and currency 11.1% so cash yeah
other loans and advances so
miscellaneous loans and advances 7.7%
and the government will make loans to
other countries to help them out with
you know food shortages things like that
yep but 45% taxes taxes receivable 16.4%
student loans 45% w
so what we're saying is almost 50% of
the business of the US government the
cash that runs the machine that is your
roads that is your FBI that is your
government that pays the salaries of
your congressman and women is student
loan repayment yeah it will not go away
because it's the half of the economic
engine if that goes
[Music]
away or it's not half the E economic
engine it's half the assets that's a
mess that a scary scary place to be M so
I say that to set the stage for this
idea if you're waiting for these to go
away they're not going anywhere and not
only are they not going anywhere but if
you don't pay the piper you're on the
hook for some serious uh business here
we actually at Ramsey Solutions we put
out articles all the time about uh
topics that are important to you guys um
and we recently put out a topic that
said what happens if you don't pay your
student loans because I know I'm getting
up in folks grill right now but I know
there's a lot of of you have just
decided I'm not going to pay it that's
okay I'm just not going to pay it and
let me tell you why that's a terrible
idea number one we just said because
they're going to keep making them and
number two it says uh federal student
loans owned by the US Department of
Education and Federal Loan servicers
have the power they have the full power
of the government behind them to get
this money from you of course they do
and they're not going to sleep on that
because we need the money as we've just
explained so if you decide that you're
not going to pay your loans let's walk
through a couple of the things that can
happen to your butt number one if your
loans be your loan will become
delinquent immediately after you miss a
payment so if you mess around in October
and you're like you know what I'm not
ready I'm just not going to pay it uh
you'll be delinquent and you can you
will be charged a late fee up to 6% of
the monthly payment that's crazy so add
that to the interest late fees terrible
next thing it says uh your loan service
will then report your student loan as
delinquent and if that goes on for more
than 90 days of course they're going to
report it to Experian uh Equifax
TransUnion that's your credit report so
now it's going to start to tank your
credit score if you keep letting it go
on past that it goes into default um and
this usually happens after about 9
months of Miss payment so you're totally
in default okay and once your loan gets
into default so once you've gone about 9
months without paying your loan here's
what will happen your entire amount
you're so let's say you owe $80,000 the
entire amount becomes due that's called
loan acceleration and it's a very real
thing it's a very scary thing so if you
think that you're going to mess around
and just willy-nilly like I'm not going
to pay it they they can't make me you're
getting into some really serious water
here if that happens at this point
you're in default and it's reported
again to the Credit Agencies but if even
if you wanted to apply for deferment
forbearance you can't at that point
you've already proven you can't be
trusted you're no longer eligible for
any of the income driven payment replans
right payment repayment plans so if
after you know being delinquent for 90
days finally decide for nine nine months
you decide oh you know I think I'll do
the save plan no you can't do it or I
think I'll jump into one of these idrs
you can't do it okay you won't be able
to apply for any more financial aid
which that's probably the only Silver
Lining here is you can't go further into
debt by applying for more student loans
if you go this far down the road which
is good um but here's here's the kicker
it's the federal government and uh they
can reach their old Winnie the Poo paw
into your Honey Jar called your bank
account and they can garnish your wages
uh they can take your Social Security
they can take your tax refund they can
take your passport many people say no
they can't no they can't how how would
they get it remember when um I think it
was both the Trump Administration and
the Biden Administration wrote checks
for coid and they magically appeared in
our checking accounts direct deposit
that means it can come out also now this
is talking about garnishing it from your
check that your check's just going to be
hundreds and hundreds of dollars lighter
yeah but I think there's a step past
that y'all they have proven in the last
few years they have the technology to
just put stuff in your account which
means they can just take it take it out
yeah when you wake up and you're like
wait a second I'm supposed to have
$3,000 why do I only have 200 or zero
and you're looking like Will Smith in
the Pursuit of Happiness the problem is
they just went into your account and
they took your money because you owed it
and you decided not to pay and so this
can get very seriously very quickly and
I hear I hear uh naysayers in the
background John sometimes I can hear the
peanut gallery you know throwing peanuts
at me even here on the on the air and I
hear somebody going but Jade I'm doing
the the 12 month
onramp I don't have to pay it I'm doing
the 12mon onramp and what that is is is
in a stroke of Genius Biden has said hey
for 12 months if you're not ready to pay
you don't have to pay and we won't
report it to the credit card companies
we won't uh count you as delinquent and
a lot of people are thinking hip hip
hooray that's great but what will happen
is you're still going to be charged
interest and so your balance is going to
continue to go up guys you can run but
you can't hide when you sign your L your
name on the dotted line you owe the
money and there's nobody coming to save
you not when the student loan industry
is making up
45% of us assets they ain't going
anywhere you're going to have to pay the
debt and we want to help you pay the
debt we're not saying this to get on to
you we want to help you there is a way
out that's all I got to say there's a
way out